[Music]
donald trump jr
is here with an update on his father's
condition don thanks for joining us
first we're really sorry
about this news have you spoken to your
father since he was diagnosed
and how is he you know i spoke to him
this morning uh you know obviously he's
taking it seriously but
really he's you know business as usual
with my father you know i've known him
for a long time i'm 42 years old
i don't know that i've ever seen him
sick i don't know that i've ever seen
him actually have the flu or anything
like that
so you know he's obviously taking it
seriously but he's a fighter i know he's
still working i know he was speaking
with
various senators uh about the stimulus
package today
uh it's going to take seriously but if
anyone can beat this so
do we have any sense of how long he'll
be staying there or is that unknowable
you know it's unknowable i know they're
bringing them the wall to read not for
anything in particular other than just
to have an abundance of caution for the
leader of the free world so
they're going to have him there uh so
they can be under more close observation
than they could do under the white house
uh but he wasn't brought over there
unlike some of the conspiracies i'm
thinking out there for
anything more than just that abundance
of caution
right i mean it makes sense i mean he's
the and by the way i've no
independent detail but he's the
president united states of course
they're going to want to get him the
best medical treatment they possibly can
just prophylactically
um so what what effect does this have
on the work that he's doing running the
country and on
his re-election campaign listen
obviously i love him on the road for the
campaign that's something that he does
so well he loves that he feeds off of
that
uh the enthusiasm is very palpable as it
relates to running the free world i
don't think it changes anything i mean
he's a worker he's always been a worker
tucker for the last few months
uh when i speak to my father it's
usually after midnight and he's still in
the oval office he's working uh
whether it's boosting the economy
getting that going again whether it's
dealing with covid during the crisis
my father's always been a worker he
doesn't sleep much and he works hard
uh and he's gonna keep fighting that's
you know that's what he's gonna do
uh right here right now for the american
people so
nothing's gonna take a back seat
obviously he can't do the public
appearances
that he'd otherwise be doing right now
he's going to take that very seriously
uh but he's going to be out there he's
going to be working hard as i mentioned
he's speaking with senators
he just wants to be in the action that's
that's the way he is i know
ivanka and jared tested negative earlier
i tested negative earlier as well
since we were in proximity with him on
you know on tuesday
uh so the rest of the family seems to be
holding up great which is you know
also good news and you know we look
forward to sort of letting that
incubation period go through and
also getting back to work so
this has been floating around on a
pretty wide scale since
march and your dad has been pretty much
out there since march he hasn't been
hiding anywhere he's been talking to
people
a lot of people and doing a lot of big
rallies here he gets it a month before
the election
it's a little weird how did he get it do
you think
you know what i i don't know the reality
is you know the protocols around my
father are pretty amazing like you know
kimberly got it uh earlier this uh
summer
and the only reason we knew she actually
had it was because we were getting in
proximity to him so literally anyone
who's in that close proximity
is tested each and every day uh you know
so
you know if he can get it probably
anyone can uh you know
for better or worse but uh you know i
know they took really extensive
protocols and it didn't seem to matter
so i'm not sure
uh where that would have come from uh or
who but you know the reality is this is
something that you know can spread
yeah how's hope doing hope hicks his
advisor rules
she's doing well also i i just texted
her earlier to you know to check in on
how she's doing and
uh you know sort of like all of those in
the sort of you know
inner circle of the trump family you
know just really wants to
wants to get back at it obviously taking
it very seriously uh
what wants to be in the game and they're
still going to be working from you know
wherever they're quarantining and
uh you know again for an abundance of
caution and just looking to get back on
the road and get back out there fighting
for the american people
so you haven't said a partisan word um
and you're a pretty political guy
and not afraid to hold back you haven't
said anything like that in the three
minutes we've been talking now
um and i don't want to bait you into
saying things you don't want to say but
some of the reactions have been you know
outside the bounds of i would say even
political attacks
are you able to filter those out uh you
know i i'm pretty good at that
you know i i fight pretty hard i got
that gene from the trump family but uh
you know i think there's a time and a
place for all of that
uh you know obviously uh you take it
personal i mean some of the stuff is
pretty
uh pretty disgusting but i've also had
people who you know i know
are not uh on our side uh even people in
the media who have reached out you know
and it seemed
at least genuinely sympathetic uh you
know and understanding so you know
that uh leads me to believe you know
makes me feel you know reasonably good
about
uh where things are some of the stuff is
you know way below the belt it's not
worth acknowledging that
uh you know that's okay that's you know
whatever it is you know people can
decide what that is obviously as a son
as a family member
uh as an american uh it's upsetting uh
but you know it is what it is in this
world i guess these days
yeah it is it is what it is so i assume
this and again i have to ask you a
political question i assume
this changes the debate schedule right
or do we know
you know what i don't actually know
obviously you know so much of it depends
on you know
when he can get back at it i imagine
that's you know 10 14 days whatever it
may be
i'll defer to the white house doctors on
you know on the details of that
uh for me uh you know i am i did cancel
my stuff that i had planned for the
weekend we were doing a big bus tour
with jorge masvadal around florida the
ufc fighter talking to
uh hispanics around the you know the
state and had a bunch of other events
for sunday and monday and tuesday
uh basically i'm gonna take a week off
uh you know till tuesday you know
get tested again then that's basically
the incubation period as told to me by
the white house doctors if i'm clear
again
uh on tuesday night i'm going to get
back to work and fight
yeah it's the timing of all this is very
is very very
i'm sure you know nothing to it but it
is it's it's pretty weird
don jr great to see you i'm not going to
get conspiratorial on that one but yeah
i'm not a conspiracy guy and the
slightest just noting
it is it's it's a little strange um but
anyway thank you
so much for coming on thank you
appreciate it